we've spoke uh recently a little while
ago about the Transformers one which is
the
um uh ilm animated can't wait for this
thing uh so it's been like a month or
two since I last spoke uh any
developments how is it looking when will
people see footage yeah well I don't I
don't know about when we'll see it it'll
be a while
um
I'm I can't tell you how excited I'm
getting about it it's one of those
things that like it just keeps
progressing in the right direction you
know you never know sometimes when
you're making a movie or you're like
well I think it's working everything I'm
seeing is working and it's exceeding my
sense of what it was going to be so I'm
really excited about it it is a very
fresh and different look
I would say different than any animated
movie you've seen so which is a high bar
to set but ilm is capable of delivering
it but also it's the imagination of our
artist and our director
um and
you know one of the great things is as
you actually put the voices to the
characters you know when we first
listened to Chris Hemsworth's voice
you're like God is he going to be a good
Optimist you know you start obviously he
starts as a Ryan packs and you don't
become Optimist for a while
um so he's not playing
for most of the movie what we think of
as Optimist Peter Collin
so it's that transition that that and
Chris's voice has a Timber that it it
reminds it it's logical that he you know
the Peter Collin would take over that
voice if you would which is really great
for the fans are going to really feel
great but Scarlett is amazing and it's
just coming alive in a way that um
it's really rewarding and I and it just
we had confidence in our director and
all he's doing is giving us more and
more